[Music]
that's a groove and those boys have
still got it after all of these years
you had New Kids on the Block will
headline one of the biggest tours of the
summer with Paula Abdul and boys to men
but when I joined them in rehearsal a
new kid named lumpy stole the show we'll
get to that of course but did I mention
they still got it most of you all are
fathers but there's not dad Bob yeah
we're trying to keep up with our past
selves yeah I mean are you working out
though for real sure okay oh we can Jack
definitely know dad bods here and these
guys are all in their 40s so yeah
they're careful about the menu but not
always for the reasons you might expect
our youth you know if there were cold
cuts it usually be like frisbee toss and
just yeah and that's bad for head yeah
so we can't say we've grown out of that
we just grew smart enough to know that
don't bring the cold cut guys are
gearing up for their new tour that kicks
off next Friday rehearsing their single
from their latest EP thankful and that
little cutie right there well that's
lumpy Donny's pup who crashed our
interview and will of course be hitting
the road with the band
lumpy police's us so if anyone's
screwing up he comes in Hilda growl at
you during the tour will there be any
shirts off I'm asking for a friend
we take advantage of Danny and we take
its shirt off so um you know we take
turns but I don't think this tour do the
girls stick and I know they still go
crazy but do y'all still like if panties
thrown okay it's not so much panties no
they do a row they're in love yeah
something else that happens with new
kids go on tour their kids show up on
stage what you won't see though Donny's
little brother mark
you know Marky Mark can you ever
convince Mark Wahlberg to get on stage
and do something we got him on stage he
didn't do nothing we did get him on
stage and we had to get pixie sent to
help us I thought he might lip-sync
something it
give me one more night to love you
[Music]